hi everyone today in this video we're
going to talk
the Koopman operator and how we can use
it to analyze nonlinear differential
equations and in some cases we find very
interesting results that a nonlinear
ordinary differential equation can
actually be simulated using a higher
dimensional linear dynamical system on
observable functions of our state
variable and we're going to show that in
some cases some limited cases you can
actually use this to develop nonlinear
optimal control laws which is really
exciting this is joint work with Bing
Brunton josh proctor and nathan cuts so
the Koopman operator has been around for
quite some time
Koopman in 1931 in the Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences put
forward this paper Hamiltonian systems
and transformations in Hilbert space and
in this work he outlined how you can
think of finite dimensional but
nonlinear differential equations as in
terms of this Koopman operator which is
an infinite dimensional linear operator
that acts on the space of all possible
observable functions of our our state
the the state of the ordinary
differential equation and this operator
theoretic perspective is very appealing
in some sense that instead of having
these nonlinear differential equations
with chaos and all kinds of the
associated troubles now we have a linear
operator on the hilbert space of
observable functions but the trade-off
is that this is now an infinite
dimensional linear operator with all of
the associated difficulties so recently
egor message has been looking at how you
can think about data-driven dynamical
systems in terms of this Koopman
framework and in the last 10 years or so
there's been a lot of interest around
using Koopman operators to study
nonlinear dynamical systems to simulate
approximate systems for control and
things like that in 2009 and 2010 there
was a strong connection made between the
Koopman operator theory for nonlinear
dynamical systems and experimental data
from flue
mechanics which really created a lot of
interest in this Koopman operator
framework and if you want to read more
about this there's a couple of great
review papers that you can read a lot
more about about Koopman analysis the
history the applications and and some of
the the implications of this infinite
dimensional linear operator for
dynamical systems so today we're going
to talk about when you can really use
this infinite dimensional linear
operator and when you can obtain finite
dimensional approximations on a
observable subspace that are exact okay
so a little bit of overview about the
Koopman operator we have some dynamical
system x equals f of X we consider X to
be the state of the system this could be
a very high dimensional vector of fluid
velocities at a bunch of point locations
or it could be the position and
velocities of all of the planets in the
solar system lots of examples right this
could be the angle and velocity of a
pendulum right so you have some
dynamical system generally where we're
interested in nonlinear dynamics that
are a little more rich and interesting
and describing physical systems and any
time you have a continuous-time
differential equation like this you can
always represent it as a discrete-time
update in terms of this flow map
operator so if I have some position X at
time 0 I call this X naught then I can
integrate that that initial state
through my velocity field f of X to some
point later at time t naught plus T so
this is the time T flow map that
advances States forward according to
this dynamical system and either these
perspectives is totally valid I like to
think about continuous time differential
equations sometimes other times I think
about dinah discrete time dynamical
systems so for example when I'm
collecting experimental data from
measurements at discrete times I might
think about that as a discrete time
dynamical system and the Koopman
operator is this beautiful operator it's
an infinite dimensional linear operator
that operates on the hilbert space of
observe
functions G on our state X so let's
break this down a little bit we have a
state space X X is just it lives in some
vector space or some manifold and
there's the hilbert space of all
possible observations i could make about
that state i could just measure the
state i could measure the components of
X those would be kind of linear
measurements I could measure x squared
or sine of X or all kinds of
measurements I could take of my state
and those measurements are given by
these functions G and they form an
infinite dimensional hilbert space so
what Koopman realized and this is a
really important realization is that we
can define an operator this K sub T
operator this Koopman operator so that
the way that it acts on observable
functions is to return that same
observable composed with my flow map my
time T flow map and what this means is
that if I take the Koopman operator
applied to an observation at time k at x
at time k what I get back is that same
observable function I say measurement
applied to the flow map of XK which is
my measurement at the next time step k
plus 1 so this is very powerful this
says that I have a linear infinite
dimensional operator K so that it tells
me what my measurement will be at the
next time so it's a linear way of
advancing my observable functions
forward in time which is really cool so
it's a discrete-time update on my
observable functions but again these
observable functions live in an infinite
dimensional hilbert space and so K might
actually be quite complicated now there
is a continuous time version of this
Koopman framework so we could say that
the time derivative of my observable
function is this continuous cut
continuous K times my observable
function where this is the infinitesimal
generator of this one parameter family
group so this is kind of the Koopman
framework we trade the the non-linear
kind of rich chaotic dynamics up here on
a finite dimensional state space
or linear but infinite dimensional
dynamics on this hilbert space of
observable functions and I want to just
draw this as kind of a cartoon to get us
thinking about what we might want to use
this Koopman operator for so here we
have some manifold where our dynamical
system our state lives this might be the
fluid velocity field evolving in time
for flow past a wing or this might be
the position of all of the planets
moving around this is just the dynamical
system on whatever you know constraint
manifold I happen to live on and each of
these states is advanced by this flow
map F sub T this is a nonlinear
non-linear flow map so if I have some
observable functions you know maybe I
measure just the coordinates of X or I
measure x1 squared and then I measure x2
times x3 and I measure a number of
observable functions so that's this
vector value G then I essentially get
out these M measurements in this in
these Y directions in this M dimensional
vector space and so if I can advance my
state using this F flow map then I want
to be able to advance my measurements Y
using some finite dimensional
approximation to my infinite dimensional
Koopman operator which I'm calling bold
K and so the times the only way that you
can do this is if you have what's called
a Koopman invariant subspace of
observables ok so if I have in my
observable Hilbert space there are some
eigen observable functions of my Koopman
operator and those eigen observable
functions always span a Koopman
invariant subspace so that if I have
some observable function G that is
written as a linear combination of these
eigen functions when I hit that
measurement with my Koopman operator it
stays in that subspace spanned by those
eigen observables and so you can always
take measurements which are eigen
observables of the Koopman operator and
you can define a define a finite
dimensional sub space of your observable
Hilbert space where your Koopman
operator
restricted to that subspace is just an
n-by-n matrix which is really cool
now the drawback to this is that you
can't always easily find these Koopman
eigen observables so it's not always
clear from the dynamical system how to
find the eigen observables of this
operator and how to define these Koopman
invariant subspaces where I can get
finite dimensional linear models for my
dynamical system moreover for lots of
applications we would love for our
observable subspace to also include
measurements of the state itself so if
we're going to do control we might be
penalizing the deviation of this state
from some nominal value and so we would
want our observable or Koopman invariant
observable subspace to also include the
state dimensions themselves these X
variables and what we're going to show
is that that's a pretty restrictive
thing to ask and there's only some
dynamical systems that admit these
Koopman invariant subspaces of finite
dimension that also include these state
variables but when we do have them you
can do amazing things with non linear
controllers that I'll show you about in
a minute okay so this is an example
that's really great to illustrate the
power of this Koopman framework and I'll
just kind of walk you through it so we
have a nonlinear differential equation
in two state variables X 1 and X 2 so X
1 dot equals mu X means that X is either
attracting or repelling depending on the
sign of mu and X 2 dot equals lambda
times X 2 minus X 1 squared the idea
here is that if lambda is kind of a fast
attracting eigenvalue then X 2 is going
to adhere on to a manifold given by X 2
equals x1 squared very quickly that's
what's shown here in this red dashed
parabola so here I have three initial
conditions and I'm showing you the
integration as I run these initial
conditions through the system for a
stable mu and a faster stable lambda so
you see that rapidly these trajectories
kind of come up to the manifold
and then they slowly follow this
manifold down to the fixed point at zero
zero okay so this is a simple dynamical
system it's got an isolated single fixed
point we know lots about this system we
can simulate it you know in MATLAB using
OD 45 no problem but what I'm going to
show you is that with this Koopman
framework you can essentially represent
these nonlinear dynamics using a linear
differential equation but on a higher
dimensional space defined by these
observable functions okay so what we're
doing here is we're going to assume that
we have some new coordinates y1 y2 and
y3 and that they're given by our
original two coordinates x1 and x2 but
also by this new nonlinear observation
of x1 squared and in these new three
coordinates y1 y2 y3 we can write down
our differential equation this way so
the first two rows of these Y dot
equations are my original dynamics ok y1
dot equals new times y1 that's just
another way of saying x1 dot equals mu
times x1 y2 dot equals lambda times y2
minus lambda times y3 that's another way
of saying x2 dot equals lambda X 2 minus
lambda x1 squared because that's what y3
is and then you can take and you can
actually write down this DDT of y3 and
we're defining y3 to be x1 squared so
this is d DT of x1 squared and if we
just apply the chain rule we get X we
get 2 times x1 x1 dot ok and if we plug
in X 1 dot from up here we find that
this is 2 mu x1 squared and lo and
behold that is 2 mu y3
so even this new nonlinear function y 3
equals x1 squared can be represented
linear linearly in terms of this new set
of observables ok and here what I'm
showing you is a three dimensional plot
of these trajectories for this Koopman
linear system this is an
honest-to-goodness linear system right
there's no nonlinear terms here it's
written in terms of these observable
functions which are non linear in X and
if I follow these white trajectories in
this this 3-dimensional Koopman linear
system and I follow what happens to
these first two coordinates i exactly
reconstruct my nonlinear dynamics which
is really remarkable so this has been
kind of the promise in the hope of
Koopman all along is that for non linear
dynamical systems I can find some
compact linear representation that
allows me to follow trajectories of the
nonlinear system using linear linear
analysis which is really cool
now what I'm going to show you is that
to do this exactly so that you know this
Y dot y 3 dot equals a function of these
Y ones Y 2 s and y 3 s there's only a
very few types of systems where this is
even possible right so this is not
something that you can universally do
for any nonlinear differential equation
I'll show you some examples of where it
fails but when it is possible you can do
amazing things with with control on this
Koopman linear system ok and I'm just
going to make an aside that once you
have this Koopman operator restricted to
a Koopman invariant subspace that's a
fancy way of saying that when I write my
dynamics and these variables they're in
some sense closed with those variables I
can take the left eigenvectors of this k
matrix and i can use those to find what
the eigen observable functions are for
my system of interest so here I look at
my left eigen vectors C of this K
operator and I find the eigen vectors
associated with the different eigen
values mu and lambda and to Mew and I
get these invariants these Koopman and
variant eigen functions ok I can
observable functions so in another video
we're actually going to write the code
to simulate this surface and we're going
to kind of rotate it around in MATLAB
but for now I just wanted to kind of
introduce you to this non linear Dinah
all system and how you can exactly
represent these nonlinear dynamics with
linear dynamical system on these
nonlinear observable functions okay
and when you can do this when there
exists these closed Koopman invariant
subspaces you can do amazing things like
Koopman operator optimal control okay so
I'm taking the same exact differential
equation you know it still has these
linear terms these nonlinear terms but
now I'm adding some control inputs so I
can actually actuate this x2 variable
with you my Koopman linear system with
inputs has the same Koopman operator K
and the inputs still only enter this
second variable y2 and what's really
neat about this is that you know for now
I can I can assume that I have unstable
Mew or unstable lambda or whatever you
like it can be stable or unstable and
now I can start doing really interesting
things like I can actually apply lqr to
this Koopman linear system okay so I
could have an lq our cost function where
i penalize deviations of my state x from
zero so i'm going to try to stabilize
the system to zero and I also want to
jointly weight control expenditure so I
don't want to spend too much control
input you to get my state to zero and so
what I'm trying to do is minimize this
cost function J with a choice of a
controller okay and usually our
controller looks like u equals minus
some matrix K times our vector X this K
is a controller it's not my Koopman
operator this is probably bad notation
let's call it this K tilde and so
instead of doing optimal control on this
linearization we're gonna do an lq our
optimal control on our Koopman linear
system so now we're going to get a
controller u equals minus K times my
bigger vector Y of my nonlinear
observations of X and when I actually
write this down my nonlinear optimal
controller has linear terms K 1 times X
1 K 2 times X 2
like we expect with lqr but because my
third observable is non linear in X my
third term of my controller is nonlinear
so this is super cool I get a nonlinear
optimal controller using this linear
Koopman Koopman framework and in another
video we're gonna go through the code
for this and you'll see how we actually
you know develop this in MATLAB and
actually go through the entire solution
but for here I'm just going to show you
the results so here we see the phase
portrait of X 2 versus X 1 the red
dashed curve is my Koopman optimal
controller whereas the white curve is
the lqr controller just on the naive
linearization and on the far right you
see the cost function the integrated
cost function over time and our Koopman
optimal controller has about one third
of the total cost to stabilize the
system so that means we get to the
equilibrium more efficiently in terms of
the state deviation and the control
using this Koopman non-linear controller
and so this is this is really neat this
is what we wanted all along we wanted to
take our nonlinear dynamical system we
wanted to be able to represent it in
terms of a finite dimensional linear
linear system in terms of these
observable measurements and then we want
to be able to do neat things like
optimal control so when it works it's
really powerful and now we're going to
start talking about rigorously
classifying when you can or cannot get
these finite dimensional exact Koopman
linear systems ok ok so we saw that for
some differential equations for some
nonlinear dynamical systems we can pick
a smart choice of observable functions
so that when we write our dynamics in
terms of those observable measurements
we actually get a linear dynamical
system that exactly represents the
non-linear dynamics and that i can use
to develop better non-linear control
laws now a natural question comes up
when can i do this when do my dynamics
and
met these finite-dimensional Koopman
observable subspaces that I can use for
control okay so the short answer is that
any eigen observable functions of my
Koopman operator will span one of these
Koopman invariant subspaces so if for
some you know if you have some secret
knowledge of your system and you know
what these eigen observables functions
are then you can define a finite
dimensional Koopman invariant subspace
and you can write down the dynamics on
those observables in a linear system now
figuring out what those eigen observable
functions are is very challenging
sometimes it's not clear and what we
find is that we don't just want to
advance these eigen observable functions
in a linear fashion what we would really
like to be able to do is have this
Koopman invariant subspace also include
linear measurements of my state X so I
cannot only advance these measurements
of X but I can also advance the state
itself and this is really important
because if I want to develop an optimal
controller where I'm penalizing
deviation of X then I need to know what
X is doing and you know an ideally I
would do this in a linear framework so I
can use l QR or H infinity controllers
so to advance the state X we have to be
able to represent the dynamics F in the
span of our observable subspace okay and
what that means is we have this
invariant this invariant subspace
spanned by these measurement functions Y
s 1 Y s 2 all the way up to Y SM I have
M of them and I have to be able to
represent all of my right hand side
dynamics in terms of those those
observable directions or those
observable functions so that I can hope
to write my Koopman system like this ok
so to be able to advance my state right
the first n of these observable
measurements are my state I have to be
able to represent my nonlinear dynamics
in terms of these eigen in terms of
these subspace directions but it's
unclear if I do that can I then get
closure on the remaining non linear
servable functions so remember in the
example before we had this y 3 equals x1
squared and we needed this nonlinear
function to represent the right hand
side dynamics in terms you know linearly
in terms of this y3 but we might have
just gotten lucky when we had D DT of Y
3 equals 2 mu y 3 so the fact that this
was closed and that the derivative of y
3 was also in this subspace that might
have been a fluke that might not be
possible for just any old system and so
what we found after thinking about this
for a while is a couple of heuristics
that tell you when it is or is not
possible to find these exact Koopman
invariant subspaces that do in fact
capture the state dynamics X as well and
the realization is this you can't have a
differential equation a dynamical system
that has multiple fixed points or some
kind of a periodic orbit or a more
complicated attractor like the Lorentz
system you can't have that kind of
multiple attractor scenario and be able
to represent those dynamics in terms of
any finite dimensional linear system
alright this is pretty straightforward
you you can't represent a system with
multiple fixed points in terms of in
terms of a linear system that only has a
single fixed point and that's because
these can't be topologically conjugate
you can't do some kind of continuous
deformation of the flow of my nonlinear
system with multiple fixed points into
the flow of a linear system with a
single fixed point and so this is a
little bit disappointing what this tells
us is that if I have a system that has
three fixed points or two fixed points
or a strange attractor chances are I'm
not going to be able to get a finite
dimensional Koopman invariant subspace
that also includes linear measurements
of my state X but this is kind of to be
expected right we're treating out
nonlinear dynamics for an infinite
dimensional Koopman operator and if our
dynamics are really non-trivial then we
really do rely on the infinite
dimensional nature of this kumin
operator ok
so I'm going to show you some examples
of where this breaks down pretty pretty
significantly a really nice system to
illustrate this on is this logistic map
okay so it's not possible to represent a
system with multiple fixed points with
any finite dimensional linear system
there just can't be topologically
conjugate you can't smoothly deform one
into the other and so we're going to
work this out on this very simple
logistic map example okay so if I was
going to advance my state using a finite
dimensional Koopman subspace then I
would have to have any nonlinear
function in my dynamics has to be in my
observable subspace okay and so a
candidate observable subspace would be
having YK be XK and XK squared this is
the type of this should be squared x
squared at time K so my candidate
observables are my my state X and the
square of my state X at time K but if I
go through the same step and I say can I
represent my second observable function
at time k plus 1 in terms of just these
two observables
I need higher terms so let's try this
out we're gonna we're gonna take x
squared at k plus 1 and that's
essentially this right hand side
expression squared it's XK plus 1
squared and right off the bat you see
that I get X K to the fourth terms so if
I'm going to include X Squared's in my
observable subspace I also have to
include X to the fourth and if I'm going
to include X to the fourth then I also
need to include X to the eighth and so
on and so forth so this you get this
cascade of complexity where if I'm going
to include these nonlinear functions
these nonlinear observable functions of
my state then I need higher and higher
order terms for these to be closed and
so this is a very simple example where
you really do need an infinite
dimensional Koopman operator to possibly
represent these chaotic these rich
chaotic dynamics
now that's not to say that there aren't
some special Koopman eigen observable
functions that you could use to write
represent the system in a finite
dimensional subspace but those
observable functions are not going to
include linear measurements of our state
they're not going to allow us to advance
X itself and we also have no way of
determining what those those eigen
observable functions are and there's
just some interesting kind of math
properties here that you notice that
each of these rows in my Koopman
operator are shifted rows of Pascal's
triangle times higher and higher powers
of this parameter R so you get some
beautiful structure when you start
expanding out interesting nonlinear
differential equations in terms of this
you know you pick a basis for Hilbert
space and then you expand out your
Koopman operator and you see some
beautiful patterns and I encourage you
to try this on you know just name an
interesting dynamical system and start
playing around with it and you can also
see what happens if I truncate this
let's say I only keep the first five of
these variables and I just chop this off
into a five by five matrix it turns out
for these very chaotic systems you don't
get very good predictive value for for
many iterations and you know I was
unable to find any good approximations
to this these dynamics using a finite
dimensional linear system so that's
still an open problem but based on our
understanding that you can't have the
same flow topology of a nonlinear system
with multiple fixed points and a finite
dimensional linear system there might
not be a nice closed form solution to
this but there are some cases where this
actually works better than others the
logistic map is particularly nasty super
chaotic here's a simpler system this is
an OD e with a single isolated fixed
point so that's good but it has finite
time blow-up right X dot equals x
squared will blow up to infinity and a
finite time and if you write out the
Koopman expansion you'll see that if I
pick these various functions X x squared
X cubed x forth and so on
then my Koopman operator actually has a
very very simple structure this off
diagonal increasing 1 2 3 4 etc etc and
you can work through this yourself just
by computing like let's say I wanted to
compute D DT of y3 right and y3 is X
cubed so that's D DT is 3x squared X dot
well X dot equals x squared so this
equals 3x to the fourth and that's why I
get this 3 times y 4 or X to the fourth
so easy to compute these four simple
systems of your own choosing you could
also try a different basis instead of
polynomials you could try you know signs
and things like that and what we find is
that for this system even though there's
no exact finite-dimensional Koopman
subspace that also includes X there are
ways to truncate this where you get
better and better approximations of your
full system so here's a MATLAB
simulation the white curve is my full
system for some time and these different
colored lines essentially show what
happens when I take the first you know
one by one sub block or 2 by 2 or 3 by 3
or 4 by 4 and as I increase the the rank
of my Koopman a linear approximation I
actually do get better and better
agreement with my full system so this is
promising even for systems that are a
little bit nasty where there aren't
these exact these exact Koopman
invariant subspaces of finite dimension
that include the state you can still do
approximation ok so this has been kind
of a fast overview of how we can look at
nonlinear dynamical systems and in terms
of these finite dimensional Koopman
observable subspaces in particular we
want subspaces that include the state
itself because then we get a linear
system that walks our state it evolves
our state and if we can find that then
we can do some really neat optimal
control on this Koopman linear system
but alas you are trading nonlinear
dynamics on a finite dimensional state
space for infinite dimensional linear
dynamics with the Koopman framework and
so we found that in lots of
circumstances you just can't get these
exact Koopman invariant subspaces but
that doesn't mean you can't approximate
them and you can't do truncation and you
can't do control so there's tons of
interesting areas to keep going and keep
looking
in this framework and we just wanted to
share this with you if you're interested
you can read more on the archive here
are my co-authors and we'd be happy to
talk over email or in person about this
thank you